thomas petrue what the [ __ ] are you
doing dude another day
another tick tock feud and this time
the beefs between hype houses thomas
petrue and
sway house's bryce hall we talked all
this [ __ ] come on that is cool
we did some come on what's up
yeah you might have thought these two
were friends because they both popped up
on each other's youtube channels
on saturday we should pull up and cover
her entire car with picture your face
down that sounds hilarious and since
bryce told et in june that he was down
for a sway house hype house collab
collaborations together um on different
products
different um social media platform
collabs yeah
definitely 100 but fast forward to
august
and guys things have
changed the whole world knows it
here's everything you need to know and
guys you might want to buckle up because
it's a wild ride there's like some
sketchy stuff going on
last month bryce threw some major shade
at the hype house on twitter
saying they were quote full of lies and
[ __ ] ass content
oh damn them fighting words and he
wasn't done
he went on calling them the epitome of
scum
but the 20 year old later deleted that
not so nice tweet
and while it's still not clear what
prompted the hate
thomas chimed in on instagram hitting up
the comments section of a tick tock news
account
quote kids content is literally only
talking about us at this point
the hype house co-founder added that
they make the same content
and encouraged bryce to talk about
something more important
like lebanon following the explosion in
beirut last tuesday
yeah bryce didn't do that instead he
continued the smack talk
referencing one of thomas's recent
videos i definitely did this myself
calvin and patty definitely did not fill
the entire club with these
quote thomas is 22 filling his pool up
with colorful balls
we're on two different levels buddy stay
in your lane
thomas corrected bryce saying he's
actually only 21.
and then he brought up bryce's arrest
for drug possession earlier this year
and accused him of bullying people for
clout
shots freaking fired then to
absolutely no one's surprise the former
pals unfollowed each other on instagram
and naturally bryce made a youtube video
about the whole damn thing
your content's fake everything that they
do is fake it's all [ __ ] content they're
filling
pulls up with balls like what kind of
[ __ ] content is that no
way holy [ __ ] you're a [ __ ] savage
oh and did i mention bryce wants to box
thomas
yeah like fight him sort of like when
logan paul boxed youtuber ksi
last year you know my address buddy you
do come through
yeah according to bryce thomas isn't
into it
we wanted to avoid that as best we could
when it caught up with thomas in
february
he insisted the hype house is all about
love
i want to be the positive the people
that are open to everybody that don't
hate anyone that
has is all about just literally like it
sounds silly but just making a good
environment where everyone loves each
other and everyone cares about everyone
on this platform and we're like
just having fun with it